hey what's up everyone Matthew and Cena
here I'm joined by a wonderful guess I
have Maggie and trio so you've seen her
on the show before and today for those
of you guys joining us we are going to
do a demo in appropriate and Maggie's
gonna make me an amazing illustrator and
designer in this tool because I've
honestly have not spent any time in
procreate and I barely know how to use
it so Maggie's going to help me make
some amazing works and for people who
don't know who you are you want to
introduce yourself to our audience like
you said I am Maggie and Torrio's I'm
known as little patterns on the internet
a name that I sort of regret these days
but I'm a professional illustrator
I work in procreate almost exclusively
these days so I've made the transition
from ink drawing to digital drawing and
I'd wanted to show you how to use one of
my favorite apps not just because it's
great but because I also have a workshop
coming up here yes Angeles in two weeks
in which few weeks that's right she's
gonna be here live in the studio and we
wanted to give you guys a preview of
some of the exercises that we might be
doing there it's gonna be a full-day
workshop
Maggie's gonna give us all the tools
that we need to do what we need and even
for novices like me who's okay at
drawing not really a duck don't really
know how to use the tool she's gonna
help us look like a pro so for those of
people who are unfamiliar with your work
do you have some work that you couldn't
show them that might give them a breadth
of what you do yeah I do I sorted it
doesn't usually look this really good
yeah so what
my work is floral and botanical in
nature it can vary but for the most part
is identified by really dense pattern
illustrations everything is built in
here really the only thing I don't do is
when I have to vectorize
so this is a raster based program and I
use it all the time
so these are just a few pieces I've done
in the past couple months I work a lot
in black and white but really thanks to
the addition of this in my tool kit I've
been able to migrate and start working
in color a little bit more which has
been really an odd transition for me I
used to work really just with micron
pens mm-hmm so never colored anything
was kind of nervous to color because I
don't want to like ruin the original so
she's great
oh yeah okay this one this actually was
the commission from procreate itself for
the update 4.3 which included the
addition of the text tool so this whole
piece was designed around the lettering
and the ability to add typography into
your compositions without having to use
on the outside platforms and this took
me like 30 hours okay so yeah it took a
lot have 30 hours today we have about 45
minutes to an hour yeah but you'll be a
professional illustrator by the end so I
can probably draw that like that little
flower right now okay so that's good so
for me just to be completely transparent
and honest I'm I'm a total novice at
this stuff I look at this will work and
I'm I'm a little intimidated because it
looks beautiful
obviously that one's spent you spent 30
hours but maybe you can show us some
samples of some of the stuff that we
might do in the workshop and what we
might be doing today so that I can maybe
feel a little bit better yeah today look
a little bit more I can tell I hear that
a lot and they have a lot of hand
illustrators write me and ask like oh is
it worth it to get an iPad or is it
worth it to get procreate my answer is
always yes
because I do believe with keeping up
with technology
it's a really
having to scan your work you know a lot
of people who draw by hand to know that
that's just like a total pain but I
think there is a sort of barrier to
entry that iPad is like a big purchase
to make yeah but I can say with with
definite assurance that I wouldn't have
the career I have now if I didn't have a
tool like this so it seems daunting but
there are just so many wonderful things
that you can do with it and so many ways
in which it really changes and pushes
your work so I'll dive into some of the
smaller samples so all of these I did in
like 20 to 40 minutes of course I've
been using the out for a while so I'm
sure you're gonna do great well this
looks a lot more approachable so um this
is an l0 whichever you choose to think I
use the symmetry tool in procreate we're
gonna be working with that today too
because it's one of my favorites and
it's such a fun way to get that
reflected work shot kind of look but
being able to see it live so in
Photoshop you might do that and then
you'd like reflect right the other side
and start building it but in this you
can do it all live which is super cool
some weeks and then I worked I do a lot
of botanical and animal illustrations so
just did a really quick Robin I can kind
of dive into the layers panel a little
like I really keep it quite simple so
color lime background cool um one of the
biggest things for me and the transition
from hand drawing to digital drawing is
I'm not really into high tech weird like
I really am more of a
manual tactile users so all of my tools
I think of as being able to reproduce by
hand if I had to so think of it like I
see pencil layer ink layer and maybe
background color of paper so right to me
it's more about like the actual
experience of drawing and less about
using like tons of special effects right
that's a good way to think and I do the
same thing when I do 3d work if I'm
modeling a little set or something it's
like how would i frame this how would I
shoot this ever had a real camera real
lights because it adds that limitation
helps you think about the process a
little bit better so for you here's like
how would I do this with real mediums if
it was tactile and I like that that's a
really good pro tip because that will
help me think about how might I use this
digital space yeah yeah becomes a lot
less daunting that way also a lot of
people see my compositions and they're
like huge kind of scary looking but when
you really break it down it's a lot
easier so yeah yeah I'm ready to go I'm
I'm a complete novice here Ian you gave
me a little breakdown of what we're
gonna cover today so first we're gonna
start with setting up a canvas and
you're gonna show me how to use that the
text tool in here and then we're gonna
do an overview of the layers the
symmetry tool which seems like one of
your favorite tools now and how to make
that more interesting by doing masking
and leaving as as you call it and we'll
refine that the details there and that
that will be pretty much it yeah we'll
see how we'll see how far we can get I'm
excited where do I start well hope you
guys are ready yeah so if you guys are
following at home just open up procreate
and you could follow step by step
because I'll be asking a lot of novice
questions perfect so first thing we're
gonna do is create a canvas on our main
page here this is the gallery in the
upper right hand corner you can hit the
plus to create either a custom size
canvas or you can use one of the
built-in ones okay I like to work square
when possible which will become more
evident and why later on mostly just
makes it a lot easier to copy and paste
this is a raster based program like I
said so trying to set everything up so
that it works for you the best so let's
start square I set mine up to be ten
inches by 10 inches
so you'll hit create custom size okay
over here in the left hand side you can
choose millimeters centimeters pixels or
inches inches that's fine for today
make sure your dpi is 300 or else you
will get yelled at all right so I've got
a nice blank canvas fantastic first
thing we're gonna do is we're going to
change the color of our background
slightly so the cameras are happier with
this so in the upper right hand corner
in the color wheel I actually go to the
layers panel scratch that and hit
background color mm-hmm and we're just
gonna kind of create a little slightly
tonal background better all right next
thing we're gonna do is add in text so
up until now procreate did not have a
text function if you wanted it you had
to build it an illustrator or procreate
import it as a PNG and go from there
it's really easy now okay in the match
now um so you're gonna go to the tool
kit over here mm-hmm
in the add column the fourth one down is
add text so today we're just gonna be
building like a monogram kind of like
you saw the examples from before a
decorative drop cap would be the the
term we're using so you're just gonna
choose a letter any letter you can use
this for capitalization and go to do
lowercase anything so I'm gonna do an M
because for obvious reasons um next so
we want to pick something a letter form
that's probably symmetrical looking yeah
because we're using the symmetry tool
today so this will look the best for us
for demo mode certainly don't have to do
it but I've chosen something that is
symmetrical you've chosen something that
is symmetrical this will work great so
next up you'll notice our letters are
really really tiny so we're gonna hit
edit style and that's gonna bring up the
mega menu the first thing I do is just
kind of increase the size a little bit
so you use that first toggle and I just
make sure that it's like visible so that
when I'm choosing my font I can still
see it so you might perfect I kind of
know how to yeah
visible interface in the left-hand
column you can choose your fun procreate
comes with a lot built in I've imported
some fonts which is pretty easy to do
luckily but for the purpose of this demo
I think I'm just gonna oh we got our
papyrus in here yeah that was kind of an
evil edition oh look at that thing is
beautiful oh okay okay the guys are
telling me to speak up and not towards
the table because I know I have a big
head ever since I was a little kid I had
a big head look like Heine grins with it
but yeah I know hassel just sit ready
all right papyrus I was about to rock
that but maybe not so much if you did
that you think you know all the
designers are gonna hate me mmm oh yeah
next column over obviously you can
adjust if you want regular bold
condensed so it's pretty intuitive um I
really like this update it makes my life
a lot easier
so should I pick something that's like a
chunkier font typeface or do I want
something that's a more delicate
typically I work in something a little
heavier
um just the style of my line work it's
so detailed that if I want text to even
stand a chance being visible which
obviously readability is pretty huge I
pick something like a a nice slab serif
or nice what you got there Oh Gil Oh Oh
Gil that's right you know I just don't
like the width of this but I'm looking
what a semi bold I'm Gil yeah you know
it's just there's something about the
nuances of that space right there like
the
that I'm not loving and I might just go
to my trusty Oliveto Kanoa I think
that's a good choice because that's you
guys give you it at home in trying to
polish that turd if you shove to the
workshop and you chose cheese papyrus
you're gonna get the face but we're not
kidding okay yeah so I'm gonna hit done
now if you look at our canvas it's kind
of small and in the middle of nowhere so
we can do is go up to the layers panel
this is where you can change the font so
even if you wanted to change the size or
the scale of it you can do that
elsewhere but if you double click on
your layer and hit edit text which is
about half way through that's how you
get back into that menu to change things
if you highlight your letter so you
double tap and hit select all that's how
you can change the color around oh I'm
gonna choose like a light blue or green
and I'm doing that so that I can see
what I'm drawing on top of the letter
and we can always go back into justice
Lane yeah yeah so I'd really just use it
as reference so I like to use a really
light color if you've ever seen my
time-lapse videos you can see that I
like shift colors around a lot at the
beginning before I finalize I like to
have I don't like working with
transparency when I don't have to just
because you can accidentally combine a
layer or something like that by stuck
with a semi-transparent so instead I
just choose like a really readable light
color right so this is kind of was that
Giada hit - you guys can see the
contrast
okay I can do that I chose that should I
make my letter bigger in this screen
yeah so how we're gonna do that you can
do it that way you can also use your
selection tool which is the arrow in the
upper left and make sure that magnetic
is hit on and then just with two fingers
you can increase it and decrease it so
magnetics and does that make it snap it
just it doesn't distort the letters okay
it's guess proportionate details
proportionately okay all right whoa okay
now I'm sorry I'm sorry
yeah okay user error you're gonna see a
lot of that in this look at this how do
I move this thing oh yeah so it really
is just like an iPhone right so double
pinch if you want to like snap it to
size to kind of quickly pinch on it and
it'll snap in actual size all right so
now we're actually going to start
drawing okay Shh I'm sure everyone's
waiting for a whole 9 viewers alright so
in the layers panel you're gonna create
a new line layer so we're gonna start
with some line work so you're just going
to hit the plus sign that creates a new
layer really similar and working in
Photoshop or illustrator if you're super
organized right which no one is so to
start drawing you can choose a color
that you want you can choose a pen that
you want I don't think we're gonna dive
too heavily into the brush library for
today because it would probably take up
the entire lesson mm-hmm so I'm just
gonna work in black it's easiest for me
but something tonal could also be nice
we yeah we both have a little patterns
brush pack which will be a bit do people
get this if they attend the work that
you're do and this is big cuz I do not
get my brushes tell me really she's very
protective
to get him right I'm going to work an
ink smudge the fourth one down which I
built to be kind of close to like a
micron pen okay my tool of choice over
on the left-hand side of the interface
is the toggle for size and opacity
I'm gonna keep my opacity all the way up
this time guys and this one's opacity
okay so just a couple quick tips for you
before we dive in if you were to start
drawing now you can see that you are on
a separate layer than your letter layer
you can use the quick line tool which I
think you're really gonna like and I
feel like I'm gonna blow your mind in
two seconds so if you want to maybe draw
bubbles for B mm-hmm
let's say you draw a circle which no
one's good at but then you hold down oh
snap
mind blown it perfects the circle for
you we have crappy if you hit the screen
with another finger it actually makes it
a perfect circle oh-ho I'm gonna do that
again so circle and then a whole tool
snapping so now it's an ellipse
yeah and now hit with one finger on the
screen and it makes a perfect circle and
then you can lift up you can do
triangles squares diamonds lines there's
lots of options so even if I wanted to
draw on a square I could hit here tap
and it kind of protects my oh my gosh
that's just just a little tip we might
we might incorporate it we might not
doing some library now we're gonna start
with the favorite tool that I mentioned
before which is the symmetry tool so up
in your tool bar hit canvas it's the
second one over toggle on drawing guide
where is this Oh drawing guy mm-hmm now
underneath edit drawing guide will
pop-up and this allows you to create all
kinds of different grids that your pen
sort of uses as a tool so you have to
degrade isometric perspective and
symmetry so we're gonna use symmetry
hey you you're gonna want to use
horizontal symmetry which is the second
one over I'm gonna use vertical and
we're gonna click done so what that does
you can experiment whatever you draw on
one side of the symmetry line will
automatically be reflected on the other
oh that's tight yeah that's pretty cool
so I love to draw this way because let's
say I want to do like a butterfly right
in the middle I can live draw and really
see what the shape of the butterfly
looks like so it's pretty great wow
that's really quick Thanks so we're
gonna start I'm gonna probably do
something with leaves and flowers
because that's what I do
mm-hmm but I know you maybe had some
ideas yeah beaver for blobs I like
drawing little blobby things and also
because I was looking the texture at
this great new desk that we have here
and like there's all these like really
build expertly you know about
woodworking I know about milling I don't
know anything about you know many things
I do not cool so um we're both gonna
create some line work after that we're
gonna use our line work as the basis to
add color and then we're gonna leave the
line work in and out of the letter okay
so we only have a you don't have to lie
yeah so I'm gonna kind of keep my shapes
a little bit larger I would recommend
you do the same you don't have to feel
like you need to fill the entire canvas
but we'll kind of get going so if you
want to see maybe how I start yeah kind
of like he thought I'll start and then
you can start doing yours so the coolest
thing in my opinion about procreate is
that similar to a piece of paper you can
actually twist the canvas which a lot of
apps you can not I think they're I don't
actually think there is another app that
you can do that in as of now so when I'm
drawing with a piece of paper I'm kind
of constantly rotating your paper and
that's so hard to do when you have to be
upright so this allows me to actually
start building with curves in like a
calm
ergonomic way so I'm just gonna start
building the basis for my line work it
can be a little bit sketchy er but I'm
using the rotate tool to get the feeling
for what the full composition will look
like so I'm gonna turn these into knees
I work a lot in the leaf industry but
don't ask me to identify any leaves dead
plant leaves yeah I go on hikes with
friends a lot and they always ask me to
do flower identification so I've become
really good at making up fake flower
knead it out and you totally confident
about yeah I mean think of it like
studying for a test in high school look
at the presidents you learn the
presidents for the test and then as soon
as you take the test you're pretty much
over it and you can fill up your brain
space with other things that's the
problem that's kind of what I do at
leaves and flowers
I see gotcha so you remember it in
short-term memory words for the client
and then I kind of changed out of that
so I'm gonna keep building some leaves
over here one of the tricks that I will
just encourage you to do is it becomes a
lot easier to color later on if your
lines are all closed so instead of
having open pads well they're not really
pads because it's not vector right but
instead of having an open path type
style you want to close it up kind of
like a coloring book it makes it easier
it's definitely not necessary in this
app but for what we do today it'll be a
lot nicer to be able to use like a paint
bucket and drummond
okay cuz I think that's how I'm gonna
probably do a lot of my blobs I'm
thinking about this stuff and like I
want to create a lot of shapes and you
know when I do this stuff Oh cease when
I would if I have a question yeah so
like my drawing skills are not that good
and if I want to smooth blobby shape
like that out is there a suggestion that
you might have for me to do something so
I would use the eraser tool the eraser
works on that symmetry as well mm-hmm so
you can go in and you know fix the spot
that you want to fix otherwise you would
use the double finger tap too
undo the line you just made just
contract it okay I also sometimes over
con a sketch layer so I'll use something
called feels more like a pencil and then
you can sorry if you're if you're
feeling like it um it just makes it less
chemical I suppose and then trace over
once you've got your basic form built so
for the oath give the key overview so
vector and raster are two different
times types of image processing so
vector images are infinitely scalable
they're made of paths like point A to
point B rather than pixels so things
like photographs are pixels which is why
if you are watching CSI and they have
like grainy footage of the suspect and
they try to enlarge it they fake it
because you cannot add more pixels like
a picture is a picture and you can only
expand it as far as as possible and pads
are in apps like illustrator so you can
you can infinitely make those bigger
this is a raster based program so it's
more like Photoshop and luckily for me
it's not a big deal most of my clients
are fine with raster images the way I
kind of a lot of people are like Oh what
do we do when we need to vectorize that
or work and I really almost never have
to vectorize my artwork because if a
client can print a photo they can print
master artwork um doctor would be kind
of crazy if you look at my work that's
no easy feat so I encourage you if you
are interested in raster versus vector
do a little research on that it's of
like a huge subject matter you work
mostly in Photoshop right I work a lot
in illustrator when I'm doing vector
imaging so you probably work mostly in
raster so when you're working in raster
the biggest thing is just setting up
your file to be the right size for
whoever's producing it or whoever needs
it right so it's better to over shoot a
little bit too probably just in case you
need to scale something up for
later I really like this symmetry tool
it's pretty it's pretty nifty yeah yeah
how are you blobs gone over there I
think they're all right you can tell me
how crappy they are Internet or Maggie
like they're not great but again like
I'm not good at drawing so like my when
I draw like I'll have a little bit of a
shaky hand and I'm not good with making
nice broad strokes yeah I see a lot of
great artists do where they use their
whole hand like for me I draw really
tiny
yeah and I don't know if that I think
that's just a bad habit of mine so I'm
that good but you can also zoom in to
draw tiny if you're more like I also
draw a small zoom in is that why it's
little patterns little patterns those so
literal back in the day um question for
you yeah so I see that your drawing you
know symmetrically but your centre line
is off is that something you're
interested in fixing yes so over in your
layers panel on your text layer just hit
that you're gonna hit the selection tool
over here and then you can drag the be
wherever you want so you would drag your
center point to the guideline right now
when you draw it it'll just feel a
little better so you could hit your
drawing tool yeah this might work on
there okay that should make it a little
more joyful for you
much much better so um okay I'll ask the
group I'm I heard about twitch which
I've never heard about before and I know
a lot of people play live video games on
there but I was like maybe I should just
live draw on there
because I draw for like seven hours a
day anyway said then I could just open
it up for people to watch it and might
be like one of those therapy videos you
ask people like where would you want to
see her do life yeah I need you never
need company sometimes yeah I'm not
doing video games I'm just live drawing
so I have a question yeah how do i
sample the color that I was working with
so you use one finger wait let me undo
this cuz I got some weird stuff okay so
one thing so using one finger you just
hover over an area you can also you know
glide your finger around okay mind blown
I'm getting a lot of these moments just
like shoot I I'm using a larger brush
than usual as well we're just trying to
do everything big cooking show style
yeah maybe this is like one of those
cooking shows where they make it crappy
intentionally you know there's that one
joke show on on Netflix or something
like that where like they're not trying
to make it pretty it's like oh look I
did it and it's so crappy like a really
crappy version of what was intended
yeah and so I'm the really crappy
version yours is that like the pro
mine's like medium now then it's it's
getting there so what I'm doing I guess
I'm doing sort of like a Victorian thing
I see I don't have any kind of real
concept am just trying to fill in the
space we're gonna do some cool stuff
about them okay cool any tips as you see
me struggle yeah well I'll show you
something that I'd like to do um using
the selection tool which is the third
one over this one so down here you have
automatic and free hand by using free
hand you can circle something in your
composition and then move it so that
blob mm-hmm yep now you would use your
arrow tool and you can move that
anywhere
yeah yeah so sometimes that's really
nice like if you're trying to get a
large area of work done you can use the
symmetry tool so you're getting double
the illustration then pick out pieces
and sort of randomize them mm so you
could that's a that's a very good trick
that we use in motion design a lot which
is duplicate scale rotate so you you can
animate one cool little thing you
duplicate that you scale and rotate and
then offset it and then you just
multiply that ten times and it looks
gorgeous I always look at that in like
battle scenes I see if I can spot the
same guy twice right which is like early
lion king like that was it whoever the
buffalo yeah yeah like you see the same
pattern some of them so you can see the
sprites it's like oh that's that's a
group that they animated once and yeah
populated or angry okay so now I'm gonna
get back to my brush I'm gonna continue
filling this end I just I feel like I
feel like I've got something there
sometimes I'm just sitting there drawing
for so long and well let me ask you guys
why because I we used to be on Twitch
for a little bit but we didn't want to
add more efforts to our plates just
because we wanted to have at least one
platform well and we tried Facebook for
a little bit is there a huge artists
community on Twitch and do you guys
prefer it there versus something like
YouTube or Facebook and why I'm curious
I'm just doing some user research right
now yeah I need to look into it when my
friend's brother-in-law is like the
Tetris Tetris King in general and then
also on Twitch whoa yeah I have never
felt so much suspense watching anything
in my life
stop edition that's the funny thing
video games the eSports industry you
know it takes the right type of game or
the right type of commentator to make
that exciting because like you will
watch some of these things and with the
right commentator all of a sudden
there's a story there with just you know
something there's something at stake
like American Ninja Warrior yeah you
watch that yeah the commentators are
right or I think one of the og ones was
the like Iron Chef mm-hmm that yeah and
then there was a host there he's like a
very eccentric Japanese guy who appeared
in friggin John wick 3 oh my god like
this guy can do martial arts I can't
believe that this guy is so
multi-talented so I guess we probably
needed like a hype girl or something for
this live drawing you're right we need
mark to do the commentary oh yeah next
wave of my company and I'm actually
hiring I would like a hype girl all
right you won't make much I'm just
getting more and more used to drawing
under it's about comfort abilities so a
couple tips sorry I keep moving this um
a lot of people use like textured screen
protectors so that creates a more
tactile surface mm-hmm I've been I feel
like I've been using an iPad without it
for so long that at this point I'm cool
without it um the pen grip is clutch so
this helps a lot grip yes yeah he's
probably slip-sliding away over there so
bad
speaking of
this experience tough how's your
struggles
I'm only struggling with my line
qualities because I would like to have
these little teardrop shape steeper a
little bit better like I know there's a
built-in tape I picked one of your
brushes that have my taper on there
which is nice there but when I'm ending
the loop it still ends chunky yeah way
to get that the taper there is I mean
you might just not have the right brush
for the occasion so if I may show you
the tape refresh my favorite way to use
it is just to create like small drops so
that's kind of what it was designed for
of course you can use it for anything
you want but you might want to use
something that is more of a consistent
line weight like a mono line let me
double check which brush might be best
for you I would try to use lead probably
so as you like my line is kind of
tapered down at the end so that might be
better for for the dewdrop shape because
you can kind of send the line a little
bit easier which one was that
that is tapered scrolling smudge thanks
much okay the one that you told me again
I tried to break the rules right away
this is the problem with with a lot of
people people like me who think they
know it all they'll jump in or like I
know what I'm doing I'm just gonna pick
a different brush I'll pick my own thing
I mean if you want to be creative you
also go into it well mine is like so
different now cuz I've added so many
brushes over the years but if you go
into your brush library it'll be under
the inking category the gel pen brush is
really nice
you might be very happy with that one so
if you want to have pointed edges you
might just choose to do it in a smaller
user area that does not look good yes so
like the more you can also um they're
all pressure affected so if I want to do
like a thicker line I push harder and
end in a thinner line oh okay so that's
counterintuitive for me a little that
brush specifically then might be kind to
it okay so um yeah I just meant mislead
you so you can see on the brush preview
what the ends look like oh I guess I
should have told you to use one that's
got more of a taper at the end
hmm so if I look at some
that's because I do like the fact yes of
the century whoa
it's freaking huge okay let's go really
small thanks for watching me struggle to
lighten that yeah lighten the touch at
the end Oh
use our like actual material example
certain like lighter touch it means that
it ends lighter so she knows expecting
the program to do that all for me it's
like just know what I'm thinking my
intention and then it comes through on
the pin here it kind of does once you
are familiar with just you know just
like using any materials or new enter
for interface like once you've got the
way you work down pat you can kind of
start building in seven right okay so
that's much better
someone suggested this is from Michael
staccato if you use the studio pen that
was sweet things oh is that so playable
studio pens and inking yeah thank you
Michael
thanks Michael so you swatch there just
like so many threads there's so many
options here and I don't want to make it
too complicated obviously we're doing
the short demo here but okay thank you
this is much more my language yes sirree
okay no I can feel it feels a lot better
and don't forget you can use your quick
line tool as well if you want to do like
a perfect oval yeah I don't mind like
everything else is so janky already I'm
gonna embrace that I'm gonna pretend
like this is like a very rustic looking
texture here and my intention was to
keep things very imperfect and if a
novice were drawing this as ever
wait a minute what are you trying to say
that's true were sitting here for an
hour with the iPads and he didn't he
didn't even touch it
yeah that didn't even like that I didn't
even practice yes I can see that's how
that's how poorly I've done in here I
wanted to really show you guys that I'm
not perfect even though you guys don't
think I am even though I play it on TV
I'm actually I'm very not good at some
things and we've discovered a thing
that's pretty different than me cuz I'm
usually good at everything
woodworking oh my god I bet you can
build the table oh my god the heck
full-time illustrator part-time table
expert son was a new show for the
channel learning with Matt yeah watch
this new watch that I get a regular job
actually it sounds fun see I enjoy
cooking mewn been here at the office we
really like cooking we always swap
cooking recipes or stories or techniques
and but we've never cooked with each
other I wouldn't never gone over each
other's place and like tried to cook for
each other that's interesting we're the
ones that cook at home I really is so
bad that's pretty this is looking great
okay I'm so relieved you got a full
coverage that way we can really move on
yeah okay this is nice
alright so we both have a line work
layer mm-hmm okay moving on so in the
layers panel we now have two layers one
of them is the text layer and one of
them is the line art layer we want to do
a little coloring okay right you're into
it yeah cool so I'm gonna create a new
layer for color tap and then I'm gonna
move it below the line layer because I
don't want to cover my lines so you hold
down on it just a little
mmm-hmm I feel like such a new like
trying to do how could I see when you
work out there's an option
you're using your fingers whenever
you're doing the gestures yeah and then
when you're drawing that's the only time
you can use the pen yeah I feel like a
stiff really weird nah that's got it
yeah I can't be ready so one of the best
features I in my personal opinion in
procreate is that it has a lot of
different selection tools and you there
really there are multiple ways to do any
anything but one of the most streamlined
ways to do everything is by setting your
line layer as a reference layer which
basically means that no matter what
you're doing procreate is always using
your line layer to guide it and I'll
show you what that means so if I have
I'll toggle into the layers panel and
just have the word reference if I'm on
any other layer so I can move to a
different layer now then I can choose a
color and maybe like drop it into an
area of the design
I don't have to like manually color but
if I didn't have it set as a reference
layer and I tried to do that I would get
a full-screen
flat god so it basically uses it I think
procreate actually uses the term respect
so like the RET as long as you've got
something set as a reference layer then
the program respects that as the guide
layer so what we're gonna do is set we
always set our line work as the
reference layer so this one's the
reference you just double tap on it
references the third one from the bottom
right so now we go back to our color
layer if you want to be good you can
name your layers I said my hygiene is
something so how do either okay how do i
name it just click and hold you tap one
step once twice so tap on the word
itself
yeah Michel save us how do we do this
how do I rename this I rename layers all
the time oh here so it wasn't was it
dropdowns if you go here drop-down then
you're getting no just kidding never
mind
um trust me and do this all the time
this is just one of those things in live
television that's all it's all good
oh we need is right at the top of the
list so it's like a shortcut way oh yeah
yeah but they just updated all right
directly on it I just did it cuz look I
got the word color alright so I was
saying my hygiene is very important to
me only because before you if I would
work with teams and groups of people so
we passed files around all the time and
if you get somebody's file and there's
20 untitled layers yeah it's maddening
so if you work in a professional
environment especially with the team
it's really important to name stuff keep
things clean as if your mom had to use
this and pick this up after I'm really
into like I'm really into naming layers
Photoshop is great because then the
search function in Photoshop Illustrator
though naming layers is like it's fun I
love it
okay nested layers so there are a couple
ways to color number one would be to
pull from this color wheel and drag it
into the shape that you want to add it
sometimes that fill thing happens but
what you see is color threshold appears
at the top and it basically allows you
to control how much or how little you
fill so procreate is really designed
around this threshold idea so in a lot
of different tools on here there will be
like a toggle that allows you to choose
to do so for me like this shape up here
if I want it to feel that there's an
obvious gap so I go here and then drop
that and then we might just want to
slide down it may not be closed or not
yeah that's a cool it's a great tool so
you can do that there's a second way
that I really really like and it's one
of the lesser known tools in procreate
I'm gonna choose like a nice mossy green
color so the the tool is called recolor
it is in the tool panel it is over here
so it's the last column in the effects
panel right there at the end of the
column so recolor don't get scared when
you tap on it what you have is a cursor
array in the middle of your screen
mm-hmm you can press on that cursor and
guide it around the image until you find
an area that you want to start to fill
mm-hmm so if I use the same leaf that I
just was working on I would tap into
that leaf and now I can actually
continue to color the rest of this
design just by tapping a lot of
different areas that I want to fill and
another thing you can do is we can keep
our perspective on or our symmetry on so
let's say I want to color both sides at
once which we probably want to do for
the sake of time yes so going back into
the layers panel on your color layer tap
once and hit drawing assist so drawing
assist was the the one that we went to
in the the top of the interface we
clicked on drawing assist and we clicked
on the horizontal or vertical
perspective so now that you've got that
on you can go back in to recolor slide
your ruler around and now if you look
over or up here you can see that both
sides fill at the same time oh that is
awesome I'm gonna move my color layer
above my lettering so you can use that
to just kind of I think more quickly tap
around and you can see down here that
the threshold is another option for you
right so you can use that to sort of
monitor what your coloring is why isn't
doing this so you just tap once 10
points yeah so you don't need to hold
down unless you want to change the
result this is all a little technical
foul this is no this is so now you can
use the threshold to control how much
and if it really isn't a coating if
you're probably asked
and that's when you could go in and
manually color something which works
pretty much the same way that you would
expect it to work so you use your brush
tool and you can color in a shape just
like how do I button do that okay I need
to get it so I'm gonna go around I'm
just gonna kind of loosely color
everything yeah while you're working
away and it you can also you don't have
to click out of recolor but you can go
to your color panel and she's like a new
shade of red and then just keep tapping
away so you can just change color tap
change color tap and that way you can
quickly color something without having
to continuously toggle off and on right
that's awesome
hope that was the triple chocolate tears
I'm going to so boy that one yeah this
is super cool yeah I feel like I'm
throwing a lot at you Ben I'm trying to
keep up I'm really trying
it's I just wanted to make sure we got
in like all my favorite tools only one
short time yeah and this is this is a
big one it's pretty hidden in the
interface and there I feel like I didn't
know it existed until fairly recently so
I would assume that a lot of people
don't where do you go to learn like the
new stuff for procreate or like where do
you are there resources that you look at
when you're trying to learn more about
yeah so procreate directly they do
tutorials on Tuesdays oh I think maybe
Thursday's as well but they have a they
have a YouTube channel for more in-depth
tutorials and then they also do them in
their Instagram stories
Georgie is the social media manager
she's awesome
yeah I talked to yeah she's great and
she leads their social media so she's
always doing really cool stuff on there
and then in addition to that in the app
store you can find the procreate
handbook which I just recommend is that
free or is that pain it's free so think
you have to have the app downloaded
I mean you probably want to have the app
right otherwise what are you gonna do
yeah so I use that before this I just
wanted to make sure that I was brushing
up and providing all the right
information so I downloaded it and read
it on a recent plane flight I'm just
scrolling through all the pages that I
knew I kind of knew trying to find some
new tricks okay so I'm huge now what if
I if I want to go back and select that
color again do I have to go off buzz
yeah and then you would use your finger
- right so if I turn off oh yeah you
don't actually even need to do anything
else I then use your finger oh okay
so it goes hold down oh go down and then
you yeah you can slide around to find
the color thank you you're so welcome
you're a good instructor you see it's a
preview of the workshop we'll be doing
that's how big she is she knows
everything almost everything except for
how to rename a lair I bet I'm just
gonna use a lot of my somebody's like
there's not another way do you feel like
people are just screaming at the screen
that's probably my career I was like you
idiots why are you using it that way
guys we're trying our best Michael don't
judgeth man thanks for explaining
recolor e-retailers cool right it saves
so much time like I used to manually
color everything
save so much time
this is very cool
kidding kidding I mean you could just
say we can say you're right it doesn't
matter they just want the output anyway
right just so over here people can see
it but I just tried to fill in this
really thin area and what I'm using is
the flood tool at the bottom so it's
just like threshold and it allows me to
fill a tighter space it's kind of the
same as using a magic wand in Photoshop
and controlling just exactly how much I
forget the term for it but when you go
to the top it's also called threshold
threshold I think it's a yeah it's the
same same concept yeah different tool so
in this case it did not want full yellow
so I just lowered the threshold and now
I can adjust a little more on the fly
everybody loved this tool everything was
so happy today go home and use recolor
Oh I'm assuming everybody's watching at
work also right and that's what I used
to do when I worked in an office
tutorial I think did a lot of people who
watch our channel who would do that
that's how I learned milling why did you
want to learn milling I've never willing
oh well how do you know about it
I knew this guy I in Chicago who works
at a milling company and he made just
beautiful tables oh okay
so I learned how to talk about it learn
the concept of milling right and someday
I would like to have a really long large
table like with the rustic edge yeah the
live edge Oh wouldn't that be great okay
I'm done with my coloring everything
well you're in the freaking pro and
and still fudging around with this what
do people think about how amazing
Maggie's is and how terrible - I
disagree I think this is like people do
like the sealer and then people are
commenting so today Morris's Maggie I
wish you were in my teacher well Devon
she is teaching a workshop here so that
might be of interest if you're in town
yeah if you're in LA you can come join
us
yeah I taught at a um one summer after
college or during college I taught at
Italy good art camp for six to ten year
olds lived
I made the children cry cuz they got so
frustrated than our exercise are you
serious yes bad I was trying to show my
work to every look like the 8 year olds
to inspire them and they were all stand
you pressed you Christmas oh are you
kidding
like we're eight okay you'll be bad and
then I to sit down and explain like I've
been doing this for years but I started
when I was your age so you know don't
give up it felt like I just waited a
whole group of young artists let me ask
you do you keep your old portfolios from
when you were their age my mom does
right yeah all right summer just like
everyone's mom she's like I'm like mom
what are you gonna do this summer and
she's like well planning on tackling the
garage you know the reason why I ask is
I went back to my parents place recently
and I dug up all my portfolios and I
have my portfolios from high school
getting into art institute getting into
art center graduating art center and
then my portfolio now or like my
freelance portfolio and then my
portfolio now so have like over a
decade's like two decades worth where I
could see my my very crappy work from
the beginning a very very crappy design
do you ever see like the thread of
consistency like yes it's it's
mind-blowing sometimes I look at old
work yes
that maybe I also thought was garbage at
the time and maybe it kind of looks like
garbage now but I'm like oh I kind of
see what you were getting at or I see
the beginnings of this right
yeah yeah and I didn't even start
drawing flowers until I mean relatively
recently in my career mostly because I
am a commercial artist mm-hmm
I don't really do fine art I do things
that'll be sellable right clients love
flowers everybody loves flowers flowers
look good on packaging flowers look good
on textiles so the addition of florals
into my portfolio is pretty new and
really the whole early portfolio was
abstract line work and so when I look at
that sometimes I'm almost inspired by
the old work because it was somewhat
smooth much more expressive and like
less restrained and less perfect so
sometimes I try to even like incorporate
that back into my current work I'm
struggling a little bit so I'm trying to
just fill that layer but so I'm going to
my fill layer yeah that's the assistive
layer and then I'm going to recolor and
then you need to talk so mm-hmm so maybe
you zoom out and you'll see where the
yeah I would do undo undo and then go
back in to recolor and you'll see the
little guide in the center so use that
to slide with your pen instead of
clicking into the spot you want like
slide over to it mostly they just snap
down on the spring like that and then
just flood it all the way down to it all
the way down again yeah so maybe your
shape is just it's just so we can close
it yeah if you return to your line layer
you can see accident we started filling
on my language so I'm kind of screwed
right and you are you filled on your
line layer I thought I knew what I was
doing apparently no I know my thought
you guys had me set up with someone who
could be in with I am
santé have not this artery student I'm a
hack I'm willing to listen well I'm
gonna have to go I'm not some Datsun
while you're working I will take too
long I'm not gonna make this country as
I can oh yeah yeah or I mean the floor
oh yeah I just like Matthew yeah whoa
hey whoa you can do abstract you can do
whatever you want like we're not
focusing on floral we don't even have to
focus on letters so um one thing I would
advise like if you've got something that
you have hand-drawn or something in your
sketchbook that you're looking to amp up
or turn into digital art you can bring
that along and we can take a photo of it
import it into procreate and we can use
that kind of like a tracing tool and
we'll basically learn how to use these
tools in conjunction with your
sketchbook or your idea and we can build
upon it so that you can have some
digital artwork at the end and you'll be
able to go home and finish it probably
that day um but it should be fun I'm
gonna also provide some some additional
documents so while he's working I'll
show you what I built for him today so I
just built like a little file of some
parts of my old illustrations that you
can copy and paste into a composition so
I'll have some florals I'll have some
animals I'll have some patterns and you
can just take those copy and paste and
you can use those to build off of in the
workshop so you don't even necessarily
need to come with any ideas just that's
fantast all levels welcome I love that
even a noob like me yeah look at that
mom you can save this and put this
frig he said put it the background on
her cellphone
cool ok this is kind of decent enough
like you got kind of wonky there but I
don't care this is good enough
like I feel pretty proud that I could
make something like this that's because
we moved it when you're doing symmetry
but if you want to erase that or you
done
should i I went oh ok I see what you're
saying you're saying that it sucks this
is what the kids felt I feel about for
this day while he's finishing while he's
finishing I'm gonna do a little shading
over here I think we're gonna stick with
maybe like the more graphic flood style
for years but I'm going to show you how
to do a little bit of basic shading over
here so this layer that I've called
color we're gonna call that shade by
renaming it which I've now learned to do
and I'm also gonna set that to drawing
assist show so everything stays
symmetrical so like I said about
reference layer now we're going to be
shading on top of the color layer so
it's gonna go color shade line so I want
to use the color layer as the reference
layer this time so I basically only want
to be using the color like I don't want
to shade on top of my line work it's not
important so I'm going to change the
color layer to both references so now
it's assisted and reference so it is
symmetrical and it's also the reference
mmm so by clicking on this twice and
hitting select now everything is grayed
out I'm not sure you can see it because
my camera's but um much like in
Photoshop when there's an empty layer
you get that like slight pattern overlay
and you can see that the only area I can
draw in now
upon my shading layer is only on top of
the color whoa
right so any even if I tried to draw
like in the middle wouldn't show up so
you can use this for shading I like to
use an airbrush I have one here I'm
going to pick a color that's slightly
darker than the green that I was using
for the fill by doing this and then so
all I have selected is the color and I'm
one layer up and you can use it to
create the shading of a leaf so I'll do
that I mean even go an even darker just
so we can see it and I'm just gonna add
some shading it like the face huh
Philby's pretty quickly you can see it
just kind of gives it a little bit of
life a little more excitement
I'm not gonna go there because I don't I
think will slow down the entire stream
yeah you always take over from here we
can each do our own thing we're having a
great time I'm also gonna add in some
highlights because that's fun so I'm
going to keep everything selected the
way it was and I think I'm gonna throw
in some light highlights basically all I
did there was just click around grab a
different brush nothing too complicated
and now I'm just gonna hit each part
that I want to see a beam of light
cascading upon with my highlight brush
just here and there again I'm being
pretty loose about it just kind of
giving it a little extra added texture
soo how's it going over there y'all
color I'm all color texture no I think I
think what I mean I realized now it's
like there's the symmetry right here at
the middle of the beast kind of bugging
me like how symmetrical it is so I kind
of want to draw maybe a couple of
elements that just break that line so on
your line layer just make sure you don't
have so much
so you'll want to turn drawing assist
great and then you can use color drop
where use your finger to pick up the
black color I know I learned some stuff
today so while you're doing that you're
gonna do another layer it's like I'm
still doing another layer so just on the
larger leaves I'm gonna add some extra
line work kind of give it a little bit
of life so I'm just going through with a
really thin brush and adding some
texture nothing too crazy I made such
brushes so I like when I draw leaves to
have the the beginning and end of my
leaves a little bit darker and I'll show
you why in one moment so basically it
allows a little bit of depth what I
didn't do was put symmetry on some when
you turn that on right now so now I can
go through and just add a little bit of
line work and that kind of makes it feel
like the leaves are on top of them in
front of each other and so typically
when I do my compositions I do almost
the entire thing in black and white
before coloring it mm-hmm
and that's just a process thing it's
almost like an assembly line so it's
easier for me to finish like all the
black work before I even think about
color sometimes clients want to see a
little color preview and I have to
deviate from it a bit but this is I
would say this is pretty akin to the
typical style I work in just a little
bit smaller scale is it because by
eliminating that variable it helps you
move a little bit faster I think so I
think so
is it also a values thing because I know
a lot of work really is based off of how
much contrast and how are you playing
with the value
before you even think about colors yeah
so coming from a black-and-white
illustration background I really do use
the most rudimentary style of contrast
so I want to make sure I have areas of
black in areas of white so that my final
composition has like the full gamut of
color across it right I use mostly muted
tones as well so I want to make sure
that the line work is really setting
this stage to make those muted colors
richer right right so I can have maybe
you know dark line work or shading that
once it is on top of a muted color
creates the depth because muted colors
together kind of can feel sort of drab
right yeah that was a little tip from
the colored video that Greg had made but
he was doing it more as a post way to
check if you have enough contrast
between your colors but the way you're
suggesting which I've seen other people
a lot of like visual visual development
artist concept artists they work this
way or even illustrators they'll just
work black and white at first because it
helps them just think about values yeah
it's very important to think about
values before color I'll pop over
details
I'll just really quickly pop over to
another composition trying to think of
one that would be a good example I think
it's the skull cool so the skull I did
in color and the goal from in the
beginning was to do in color but after I
finished it in color I wanted to
actually explore it in black and white
again so I went in and found my original
drawing which was here and there really
aren't any areas of black like for the
most part I would say that this whole
illustration is sort of on the same
plane right there's a little bit of
contrast obviously there's some of these
darker details but it's to me lacking
depth so what I went in and did even
after I'd worked on the color version
was I added depth by having solid areas
of black and to me I felt like had I not
intended to like I started with color
and so it's almost
I didn't think about doing this but once
I went in and actually explored the
drawing and added in areas of black fill
I thought like wow I could have really
amped up my color drawing as well I had
to go back in time and make sure that I
had that contrast
so you went so you added additional
contrast to the color but yeah I did in
fact so that's how that mmm that was the
beginning which you can see is like
super zoom in a little bit because that
is it those are some little patterns oh
and so what you're seeing here is so
that's that brush the tapered brush
uh-huh so I just use it over and over
but I color-blocked it so none of my
work is this vibrant it's just a style
but when I draw it I make sure that I'm
using vibrant colors so I can really see
what I'm doing because if I'm only using
black and white or if I'm only using you
know a really muted palette I can't
really get the the feeling of density so
when I pulled it into the final
illustration it really was just meant to
be like a white texture I did not even
see that if this was printed as a big
billboard or someplace where people can
walk by it these would be beautiful
details that would pop out and was just
like wow or if it's wrapped on the side
of a building like a full bath these ten
ten sessions I am I put it I mean I put
it up online and I only had like one
person commented say I think they wrote
it like 30 weeks after I put it up and I
got a comment on this old drawing and
the person wrote whoa I didn't even
notice that pattern you put on the skull
and I was like thank you I didn't see
that at first I didn't realize so wow
this I mean it's cool I feel pretty good
yeah this is this is super fun to do now
I have a question as you were talking
about masking yes so for me I my
intention I was building this with the
intent that a lot of these blobs are
going to just be masked within the beat
yeah and then maybe I might add some
decorative element
to break it after the fact so here's how
I do that um let's let's we're gonna do
it sort of uh maybe we'll work from the
inside out so what I mean by that is I'm
gonna go in and I'm going to condense
all of my layers both the line and the
color I normally did make an extra copy
just to make sure it wasn't messed up
but I'm just for the sake of this so I'm
just gonna combine them all it's so
simple
gotta use your pincers okay okay
so basically grabbing the top layer and
the bottom layer that you want to
combine you pinch them together whoa if
I go like that it's amazing so if you
like a really large layer group big
pinch now for us I'm also going to
create a second version of this layer
just in case we need it later so you're
gonna swipe to the left and hit
duplicate
and then choose one layer and turn it
off just so it's oh that's her that's
not that cool
so at this point we could go in and have
to be on your leg that's on we could go
in and just kind of start erasing stuff
which would look like that
but so like I have this translucent
eraser thing is there a way to adjust
their easier yeah so go to painting
maybe choose something that's solid
maybe or go to inking actually yeah I'm
just putting more solid which should be
fine okay so I'm gonna turn off layers
this yes
I want it to not feel as symmetrical
anymore right um and so what I'm gonna
do in order to make it feel woven is I'm
gonna select my M color so or my M shape
so I'm just gonna toggle the layer and
hit select that makes it so that all
we're working with is the layer shape
what was that one I just tap once more
uh-huh and hit select
so now you've kind of you've grabbed
your letter but by tapping on the color
layer we'll call it the art layer now
we're working on the art layer but
keeping in mind the letter layer and
what I mean by that is if I were to hit
a race I can go in and
the part that's on top of the letter
itself is the part that's being erased
right and without what if I want to do
the inverse so you would go to your
letter layer hit select and this pops up
you'd hit enter yes that's right that's
correct and now it's showing the
selection inside it's a little hard to
see for so now you go to your art layer
may actually you may have it may need to
be outside will see yes that's exactly
what I wanted yeah so I'm gonna go
through on this side and just start
erasing some layers that overlap the M
but not all of them so that way they're
kind of going in and out of the letter
both of these and want to be floating
behind I hope that made a huge
difference
um this to me is like the most fun part
I just feel like it's a little more I am
having so much fun with this this is
it's fun very credibly satisfying now I
can ask all day yeah
things are getting a little bit more
asymmetrical yes thanks I'm going to
this guy out
any thoughts or comments from our
audience at home as they watch us do
this stuff I'm starting to feel like a
pro over here I think you're gonna be
really happy with it in the end do you
think you're gonna work in probate a
little bit yeah actually after learning
these tools I'm gonna have to watch this
video luckily we have this recorded then
I can kind of study and think about how
I might use this because the symmetry
tool like the way to draw all this stuff
and then just kind of like the intuitive
nature of using a pen versus like a
mouse or even on a Wacom tablet like
this just just feels really nice to work
with yeah so while you're erasing I'm
gonna go through and I'm not just gonna
add like a few little details in here
and there you know just gotta make yours
more intense well I just wanna make sure
that we got a lot of interesting stuff
happening at all times but I could tell
that you were the student in class if
you look what everybody else is doing
and you'll just do yours a little bit
better you're gonna probably not you've
probably never been cursed with this but
have you ever had to go into one of
those like painting One Nights No Oh a
party you know those kill me
why it's like hey everybody we're all
painting the same Corgi oh and I'm
staring like I do not want a peanut yeah
I want to pay my own thing I will take
the wine but I don't even do you end up
eating your own thing yeah I'm not
painting the Corgi like
apocalyptic corny scenes so I'm using
one of my brushes
it's a tapered dot brush I really love
it and the dot starts small and with
more pressure they become a larger so
how do I unselect this thing now I
thought when I start adding details you
would just toggle this like okay
okay this is looking cool yeah thank you
I know it's looking amazing you asked me
do you slowly use your iPad for this for
these type of drawings or do you use a
Wacom with other application no I don't
use whack on I did when I used to work
as a graphic designer in house and I
would use it there that was like before
the days of iPad but to me I have a
pretty big issue with hand-eye
coordination I want to see what I'm
drawing and I know that since the iPad
came out the it's like this in tech that
you can actually see what you're drawing
but at that point I was already a
devoted iPad user so I never
experimented with that one of my
favorite other apps though is Astro pad
so if you're familiar with that you can
actually tether so you would still need
an iPad but you could tell from your
iPad to your computer either a hardwire
or a Wi-Fi
I think tether and you can basically
project the screen of Illustrator or
Photoshop or whatever is in your
computer onto your iPad and work in it
directly with your stylus I love that so
the only problem is that you can't
rotate like you can in procreate but
let's say I'm vectorizing some artwork
so maybe I'll create the artwork in
procreate but then I want to vectorize
it separately I prefer to draw by doing
that I don't do live trace or anything
like that which no one can ever convince
me to do live trace it's just like too
messy for me so instead I would
basically save my artwork as a layer
throw it into illustrator make it
slightly transparent and then use the
pen tool or the brush tool to draw my
vector on top of it but procreate is
Scott it's just so near and dear to my
heart it really got me into digital
drawing so I'm a big fan
so I'm just adding some like more
decorative details no one has ever
accused me of being a minimalist so I'm
just gonna keep going you are - yeah I'm
just I'm just like that experimenting
and seeing if I could add another layer
of something that's kind of moving the
other direction you have a suggestion
like cuz I look again I was inspired by
those shapes in this wood table and I'm
looking how there's all these kind of
like little intricate things so you
could also try using this dot brush if
you maybe did it in like white on a
higher layer underneath maybe one layer
on top one layer below mm-hmm so if I go
here and then go to brushes go back go
to little patterns yeah yeah I really
like this brush and then you would want
oh my gosh so the harder you press also
the order in the dot said account this
pressure sensitive pressure this is so
cool I'm gonna turn off my crappy weird
what I was trying to do before yeah so
you can create brushes as well there I
could do a whole demo on that I can
really do anything but one of my
favorite brushes to create I'll jump
back over into another drawing I'm
trying to think of the last when I did
it with yes so I worked on this kind of
fake logo for a club for people that
can't keep their plants alive like me
and I really wanted to create some
interesting density that just wasn't a
solid fill so down here you can see that
I created a repeating layer brush so no
it's already intense for me cuz I
usually do it manually and it's like
this would be so much better okay I will
get into that I I love this oh my gosh
okay I'm gonna make it white just like
you suggested I tried to break the rules
again and I
listen but let me look let me show you
guys can you see that so as I hold this
down the little balls get a little bit
bigger and then if I go light you get
these very delicate lines this is this
is amazing to me what I really love too
is when I do work in vector you can
build similar brushes in Illustrator so
for things like this one like a cat like
kind of a cascading dot shape like I'll
just build a similar brush in
Illustrator so that I can use it in the
same way when I want to recreate it in
vector it's a lot of work but it's
doable I just like that the apps can
work together when needed I'm just
mesmerized by this tool this brush and
just oh this is so cool it's a good one
right mm-hmm
so how are you feeling about your colors
in general hmm they're they're okay it's
a little money now that I look at it
post like after I've done everything it
feels a little bit muddy I think
something needs to pop and I don't know
if it's the yellow that needs that pop
where this red here one or the other if
you like yeah I mean a little bit more
contrast there so um let's play around
with color a little bit hmm
so something I think also I just kind of
want to see on yours is if you toggle
off your letter layer I would love to
see what that looked like almost it's
pretty definitely legible yeah I think
it has more little details right there
just a complete yeah yeah cuz then I
could do actually another like maybe
more of like a woodgrain texture or
something back there just yeah I think
you have enough fill on it mm-hmm to
create the basis that super cool
um but feel free to talk about it back
on if you like my but I'll show you how
to use some of the color editing
functions I use them a lot the width the
color palette I start with is like never
the color palette I end with and a lot
of people ask me how I create my
palettes and the answer is I mess with
them until they look good
this is not a color palette I would
normally work in but I created it this
way just so I can kind of show you how I
can play with it so with my color this
is like the color artwork layer toggled
on you go to the adjust
panel and there are some color options
at the bottom of the adjustments panel
one that I really like to use this color
balance so it it to me it's kind of
similar to like the color toggles in
Camera Raw mm-hmm so you can choose
between highlights mid-tones and shadows
so if you wanted to mess with your
yellows it would be highlights and you
can use the sliders to affect just the
highlights so this will end up affecting
just the yellows in my drawing so by
toggling I can add warmth ah that's so
cool yours is so much better than mine
hide shading see mine's less dynamic but
you can just like I love working like
this because it takes it from just like
a green on green to something that's
like really dynamic interesting color so
especially working with shade brushes
you can get tints that you were working
with and you can just sort of use this
tool to like amp them up and make them
into color schemes that you probably
wouldn't have initially thought of so
I'm going to do this
[Music]
and so I've kind of turned my knee to
like sunset cars mm-hmm
you know like going against them that
doesn't sound like you know what do I um
give me some suggestions here I'm just
trying to select some stuff I'm looking
at the line work now which I started
with that I don't like a dark yeah I
mean I like the idea of keeping the
darkest points of it tonal with the
background of the B and then using the
highlights and the white to add your
secondary color and it is feeling a
little Christmassy yeah I might I mean
it's cool the B of Christmas but there
was nothing concept at all but I
probably go to mid-tones just I have a
feeling that's what the red is gonna be
on yeah it is and I would use that how
do I make this pop help me I'm just
checking it out you know you're judging
no I really need your judging um here's
this is my idea so let's get it to a
point that is less blood like we're
gonna go to hue saturation and
brightness and this will take everything
on the layer and uniform change it so I
think this is gonna be a good option
okay yeah pop because you can also use
the saturation feature and kind of do
like a whole batch at it I mean it does
take some of the beautiful tonality that
you had out of it so maybe there it's
like I'm there's some middle area that
looks more vibrant that's yeah marma jam
maybe I'll make my more vibrant
so I kept up the vibrancy online this is
so vibrant not like I couldn't commit um
and then you can change the background
color of the letter if you want to as
well
the cool thing about this is that the
way the text layer also if you were to
send it into Photoshop could be a live
text layer so we haven't rasterize it
fully so that part stays vector yeah and
we've clipped a lot of the illustration
to it so you probably wouldn't want to
change it into a different letter at
this point because we've clipped so much
of it specifically to the beam right but
what it means is that you can just
manipulate it a little bit easier and if
you really did need to you could go back
to the that layer color or layer where
we didn't erase anything and in
Photoshop or something like that you
could change the letter and then ream
ask the artwork to a different letter
mm-hmm so you could throw this yeah you
can I can change this to a H and then oh
kind of start from scratch and relayer
all of the leaves onto the H so then I
would have already two two matching
letters right would be kind of fun so
you could just repurpose a lot of the
same elements yeah that's very cool so
I'm gonna go through and I'm just gonna
change my letter color I actually might
mess around a little bit with background
color so I'm gonna compensated make it
pop all right
and this is fun
[Music]
all right so I think we're close to
wrapping up and are there any questions
that you guys have all we still have
Maggie here that she might answer
something that's relevant
I guess what we we've done today
questions in the chat guys that's
beautiful Thanks
the the shading helped a lot the
shadings pretty ideal I think that's
something that I gotta go back known
this I will do a fresh one where now I
know now know the tools a little bit
better okay we do another one and then
think about how I might use those things
cuz that shading it was so subtle but
once you started playing with the colors
man that made a pop oh my gosh what did
you just do right now like so will you
tell me I took the artwork layer that we
didn't destruct in any way uh-huh
basically remember I like I had made it
pink
yes so I pulled the right so this is
what I have mm-hmm the artwork layer
that we didn't distract I turned it on
hold it on top of my layer I had been
working on I flipped it vertically shoot
and then I moved it behind the letter so
gosh did we doubling the amount of
illustration work that I had on them all
right and clients don't need to know
that I told you this is a good trick as
the duplicate scale rotate also
duplicate scale rotate and offset you
have to offset it otherwise I mean if
you don't want that for we're different
this is the easiest way to make
something look very intricate yeah wow
that's em for Matthew she picked him for
Matthew can you guys believe
someone's asking what is your
inspiration behind your color choices or
where do you get nature science no no
actually usually it's just I saturate it
so that it's like really colorful and
beautiful and then I whip out all the
saturation so that's a little bit muted
I feel like my line work is the star of
any composition and I don't really want
color to compete with it it's not me so
color to me comes second it's just a way
of accenting the line work so I like to
keep a muted palette but it's fun to
color with bright colors and just pull
them back at the end right
and ultimately work with colors that
flatter each other so classic colors
color wheel spectrum applies you can
work with like colors and create a
little like I forget the term for it by
a mutual I think it's called like color
by like vibration so you can work with
colors that don't necessarily match like
an orange and a pink but when they're
together they kind of like vibrate
really cool there's a okb Michael knows
yeah what is that
is it simultaneous contrast simultaneous
contract see I didn't waste that
$100,000 education that argument for
nothing I remembered one or you can use
colors on the opposite side of the
spectrum so right that's complementary
complementary right yep that's it that's
a pretty solid starting point I also
when I use when I do shading and
highlights I like to use tonal colors so
rather than using a white for highlight
and a black for shadow maybe I'll use
like a yellow for highlight and a dark
green for shadow and then when I toggle
around there's also blend modes in in
this program so I can toggle around
blend modes and try to just create an
interesting color where's that from
there and sometimes I just look up color
schemes first might fit one of my
favorite resources for that is called
design seeds they take photographs and
pull out the color palettes and I you
could just I could just scroll through
them forever I've been using that since
college
to come up with like cool color schemes
yeah I think I'm the same I when I could
like my this is not representative of my
color is here but when I do colors the
same thing like I look for something
that I love like if it's a still frame
from a film or something just like I'll
just literally sample those colors and
start applying it and then tweak it for
the appropriateness of what I'm doing
it's just I see something if I have that
nice response like oh I love the color
that I'll just straight-up copy it
totally and then slightly tweak it yeah
you know colors their game hmm and if
you look at what I do is usually in a
pretty similar vein I thought the other
day I'm gonna start using yellow and
that's gonna be big for me because well
I've changing
I really don't so maybe you'll see some
yellowy stuff if I can figure out how to
make it nice and mute are there more
questions yeah we got one from Michael
Michael any best practices for curse oh
yeah I'll use this as a sample um so the
use this brush so we we use the quick
line feature which was the one that
created perfect circles or triangles or
squares but you can also use it to
create curves so I'm gonna use a bigger
brush just so it's a little more visible
but you can create a curve and once you
release you'll see at the top the term
edit shape and you can use that to
change your curve what did you show me
that's a minion with there are a lot of
features we didn't have forever sorry I
really like yeah so I like that because
um obviously you can create nicer curves
that way another one is in your brush
settings you can toggle on streamline so
streamlined paste basically takes the
intent of your live mark and smooths it
out
so with streamline off you know I draw a
curve like that with streamline on I
wonder if you can pick
on this do you see how it it kind of
adjusts itself as I draw so that can
help with curves I do a lot of like
swirls so streamlines really helpful
because I can make a spiral with a few
gestures but it actually stays
relatively round yeah that is crazy so I
wish you had showed me this at the
beginning well you know my Jacob loves
and loves maybe we'll have like a print
out at the workshop it's like here are
tools you can ask about creating a
perfect circle creating a curve right
like it thank you almost yeah cool yeah
all right I think that's pretty much it
like I think you dropped tons and tons
of knowledge on us
today my mind is blown because prior to
you being here I've only used this
program for about an hour total now I
added an additional hour and look how
much better I am hopefully I will grow
more with the workshop because I'm very
excited for them excited to learn some
more what the workshop will be longer
than this awesome yeah how do you talk
about the details of the work yeah so
it's gonna be here hosted kept line
you're pretty much gonna provide
everything in terms of the tools you
just need to come with your own iPad
with the latest version of procreate and
even if you've got a friend and both of
you want to come maybe you only have one
iPad between you you can share it like
we worked a little bit together today I
honestly don't think that would be a
barrier you can take turns I think it's
totally fine so don't feel like you need
to rush out and buy an iPad if you
happen to have a creative friend that
wants to share with you but I will
provide you with some cool brushes
you'll get every brush that you saw me
use today I'll provide you with some
sample files so you can dig into them
see how they were built
I'll perfect like if you show up and you
just are like I kind of just want to
color I can show you how to color I can
provide some files and you can learn how
to add shading like it'll be it's a
small group we are capping the number of
people that can come so that we can
actually work together and address
concerns on the fly but with that being
said it's pretty flexible don't worry
I've done workshops in the past
it went well every time yeah so don't
feel like you need to have something
really prescriptive in line you can come
in with just an an open heart and a
desire to play around for the afternoon
can we bring our wine and corgis I don't
know if do you have that kind of
insurance like the liability coverage in
the building I talks in hi I don't think
so I'm just sorry I opened up a box the
worm's you didn't quite get away with
regards to the iPad so is it necessarily
necessary to have an iPad pro we might
need to double check on that to my
knowledge
iPad pro the pro Creed is only able to
work on iPad pro I do believe that the
most recent version of the iPad that
came out the non pro version but it has
to be like the just that last one that
came out we have to double check on this
yeah if it's Apple pencil come right
yeah I have another iPad here and this
is like a really old iPad but it still
is procreate compatible so I would just
check if you can download procreate on
your iPad we're good to go
cool yeah and I think also for those of
you because this is a big purchase for
some of you guys who don't have a friend
or who don't want to buy it yet you
could also I believe rent these so you
might look at some computer rental shops
or even some photography like B&H or
Sammy's or something like that because I
believe they'll rent out gear so if you
just Yelp it or google it I'm pretty
sure you could rent something just for a
day for the sake of the work yeah I
think that would be valuable too because
then you can figure out if you actually
want to work on an iPad or if you can
see yourself working on one before you
take the plunge is there any questions
about the workshop that we might answer
no oh we're gonna have lunch there yeah
oh yeah people just wishing they could
come but they don't live here by
Southwest Airlines BAM if it work people
have flown out for our workshops before
and they've gotten a lot of value thank
you I'm flying out for that well I'm
driving in for the workshop but I'm not
even supposed to be here that's right
yeah and she's doing Utah yesterday
Wow's it yeah it's known all right so
cool so if you guys are interested in
taking her live workshop here at the
Future check out the link in the
description below seats are limited so
make sure you pick yours up if you guys
have any questions about what you saw
today or anything about the workshop
just leave us a comment and if you guys
enjoyed this for the many of you that
are streaming now give this a thumbs up
and don't forget to Like comment and
subscribe because it really helps us out
and if you like Maggie and you want to
see more of her look her up at little
patterns I'm all over the Internet yeah
you can find titan me and her intricate
yeah and i'll do my best to check the
comments on your youtube channel and
i'll try to write in and answer any
questions that you might have awesome
cool alright well we will see you guys
next time have a good me you maybe in a
couple weeks yeah